Since our app will have notes and
notebooks, we'll probably
need those two entities.
Let's start with the notebook.
We will need the following attributes,
name and creation date.
Name will be a string.
And creation date will be a date.
Once Xcode turns notebook into a class,
it will also turn each of these
attributes into properties.
We can also configure
the attributes over here.
Optional specifies if this property
must always be present or not.
Should a notebook always
have a creation date?
I'd say yes.
Validation rules allow you to provide
Core Data with constraints for a value.
For example,
if you have an attribute called salary,
it should always be greater than 0.
Therefore, you should set salary
to have a minimum value of 0.
Core Data will make sure that you never
save a value that is less than 0.
Now, go ahead and
create your own entity notebook.
Now, let's move to the note entity.
It will have the following attributes,
creation, date and text.
Should a note always
have a creation date?
Yes, so we'll set it as optional.
Text, should it always have a text?
Well, it might be empty.
So, I'll leave it as optional.
This transient checkbox,
here, means that the property
will not be saved in Core Data.
I wouldn't use this.
So, we'll forget about it.
Now, go ahead and create your own note.
There's one thing missing here.
One notebook will have several notes,
and a note will have only one notebook.
It's important to make sure that our
data model includes this information.
We'll do this in the next
video with relationships.